after spending the last few weeks
playing OverWatch 2 I learned quite a
few tips and tricks that changed how I
played going forward this includes what
the difference is between OverWatch 2's
battle passes how to level up your
battle pass quickly how combat has
evolved and how OverWatch 2's new Heroes
fit in with the old crew here's
everything I wish I knew about OverWatch
2 before jumping into play
as part of its move to free to play
OverWatch 2 is adopting a battle pass
system this includes both a free battle
pass and a premium battle pass which
players can buy for 1 000 OverWatch
coins or roughly 10 US Dollars these
battle passes will last the entire
duration of an OverWatch 2 Season or
roughly 9 weeks and offer a wide
assortment of cosmetics and other
goodies players can earn simply by
playing the game and progressing through
the passes 80 tiers so what are the
differences between the two passes for
starters players who purchase the
premium battle pass will have access to
any new Heroes instantly whereas those
using the free pass will have to wait
until they hit tier 55. based on my
experience with the game this could take
quite a bit of time as an hour of
gameplay will generally only raise you
up a tier or two the premium battle pass
also grants players a 15 experience
bonus meaning they'll progress through
the pass much quicker and access to
other unlocks including more intricate
cosmetics and Mythic skins another new
feature in OverWatch 2 our challenges
which can be divided into six categories
daily weekly season competitive Lifetime
and hero challenges range from simple
tasks such as winning matches or getting
a certain number of kills not only are
they the fastest way to progress through
your battle pass and earn some sweet
OverWatch coins they will also just make
you a better player which will help both
you and your teammates in the long run
chances are the first thing you'll
notice when jumping into a match of
OverWatch 2 is its pivot to 5v5 matches
whereas OverWatch featured six Heroes on
each team generally two damage two
support and two tanks OverWatch 2
eliminates one of these tanks shrinking
each team by one and subsequently
altering the dynamic of battle keeping
this in mind I urge players to focus on
the objective now more than ever
engaging in little side scraps can cost
your team the game I also encourage you
to take note of what Heroes work best
together and which ones take advantage
of opponents weaknesses for example
flying heroes like pharah greatly
benefit from having someone with raged
healing to keep them healthy such as
Mercy or kiriko in turn Farah is
incredibly effective against barrier
tanks like Reinhardt thanks to her large
Splash damage while it might sound like
a lot to keep track of it does get
easier with time and soon it will become
second nature after years of fans
longing for a way to merge their
OverWatch profiles across various
consoles blizzard is finally adding
cross progression with the addition of
this feature players will gain access to
all their in-game cosmetics and
statistics regardless of what platform
they're playing on so looking to
transfer your OverWatch skins to
OverWatch too the process is actually
pretty simple
first things first you're going to need
to log into whatever console you are
playing OverWatch on once you are logged
in you should be immediately prompted to
identify select and confirm the accounts
you wish to merge players will be able
to merge One account from each of the
following platforms Xbox PlayStation
Nintendo switch and PC once you complete
these steps blizzard will prepare your
accounts for synchronization be warned
however that if you do not go through
the steps to merge your profiles when
the game prompts you to you will forfeit
the ability to do so at a later date
furthermore once you merge a console
account you will be unable to link to a
different console account on the same
platform all players looking to merge
their accounts must have a Battlenet
account which you should theoretically
have already if you've previously played
OverWatch once you elect to merge your
accounts all your cosmetics and progress
across systems will be stored using this
account which will then share the
content across your system profiles
three new heroes are coming to OverWatch
and all of them are extremely viable
options to consider when building your
team a DPS hero sojourn is a mid-range
specialist with Incredible mobility and
artillery skills her primary weapon is a
railgun that generates energy on each
successful hit and can then consume that
power for a high impact shot much like
Soldier 76 sojourn specializes in
dishing out moderate yet high-speed
damage from a medium distance this makes
her pretty effective at taking down
tanks but puts her at risk of snipers
described as a Fierce and resourceful
survivalist many of junker Queen's moves
are most impactful at close range
including scattergun and Carnage she
also can inflict a status ailment making
it impossible for opponents to heal
junker Queen is great at taking out
lower Health Heroes quickly whether
their support or DPS but she is also at
risk against other tanks and long range
Heroes kiriko draws much of her power
from her spiritualism which is seen in
her homing ofura protection suzu an
ability to summon a Kitsune to lead her
team into battle kiriko also boasts some
impressive movement abilities such as
wall climb and Swift step the latter of
which allows her to even pass through
walls kiriko is a great asset to mobile
heroes such as pharah and Genji and can
counter massive AOE attacks such as
junkrat's Rip Tire however as a support
character kiriko can't take too much of
a beating meaning her ability to reach
allies in the heat of battle could lead
to her downfall of the DPS Heroes around
although these three Heroes might be the
only fresh faces that doesn't mean
blizzard didn't freshen up some fan
favorites for the journey ahead many of
the adjustments made to characters focus
on making gameplay more aggressive and
high speed these include eliminating
orisa's Shields mei's ability to freeze
enemies and Cassidy's flashbang
furthermore Bastion will be losing their
ability to self-heal doomfist is being
converted into a much beefier tank and
Sombra will become significantly more
deadly with reduced cooldowns and more
damage dealing attacks with all this in
mind my advice is this lean into what
OverWatch 2 is encouraging synergize and
play aggressively
so there you have it that's everything
we think you should know before heading
into OverWatch too be sure to follow
Gamespot on social media for more
OverWatch 2 coverage such as
comprehensive character guides and more
thank you for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you